[Música]
além do santos
eu sou também o marido da chile então
antes de mais nada eu queria contar pra
vocês a história do dia que eu conheci
ela dia 28 de outubro de 2001 18 anos
moleque doido um show de rock pra você
ver charlie brown junior raimundos
planet hemp o rappa só precisava levar
um brinquedo de 1 99 e mais nada
a queima roupa naquele dia estava um
calor tão calor que eu podia jurar que
uma hora a galera estava do meu lado
dançando tava nem aí mais rock estava
fazendo a dança da chuva e ali onde
estava perto do palco estava tão calor
tão abafado que mal chegava a pedir a
água que a galera dava pra gente lá
num determinado momento do show eu
comecei a olhar para o lado e comecei a
perceber um movimento estranho
do lado esquerdo e uma galera pisando em
cima do banheiro químico
do outro lado surge uma uma coluna
d'água do maluco estourou um cano
eu olhava tudo aquilo com aquele calor
meu deus que seja mas eu não ia levando
rg que tirar dinheiro para comprar água
e eu falei com essa água vai ficar
jogando agora o tempo inteiro
uma hora vai pagar isso aí eu resolvi o
problema o livro lado de um monte de
garrafinha d'água recolher todas elas
foi até a coluna d'água
lá vem uma por uma enche todas elas e
voltei para o meio do bate cabeça com
oito garrafinha de água na cintura
verei o que possui do rolê irmão estava
lá ostentando água no camarote todo
mundo é todo mundo junto
quando abriu uma brecha multidão e lá na
frente eu olhei a primeira vez nos olhos
dela
senti uma coisa tão emocionante que até
hoje não consigo explicar
mas eu sabia naquele momento que aquela
era a mulher da minha vida mas beleza
olhei pra ela ea amiga dela assume que
ela estava numa parada que a gente
consegue falar ea andar junto falei vou
lá cheguei lá oferece água muito bacana
e no auge da minha c200 e falei agora
que o negócio vai pegar
fiquei com vergonha tira a camiseta eu
falei pra ela o segura e rápida o
goleiro bate cabeça para a humildade de
cabeça
burko de onça respira volta lá que vai
dar certo
voltei falei pô segura uma camiseta mais
cabeça nem tal merece até um beijo
quando eu tomei um sonoro não
pois é gente querendo um pouquinho eu tô
cheio de vergonha caramba de ruim
e aí pouco antes da gente sair e pouco
antes na verdade da tropa de choque
entrar pra sentar o sarrafo em todo o
mundo e os bombeiros entrarem para
apagar o incêndio dos banheiros químicos
a gente saiu lá fora falei bom agora vai
dar certo vamos lá respira pediu o
telefone dela ela com toda a boa vontade
do mundo falou
susan tem 15 eu não tinha nem rg eu não
tinha nem dinheiro que dirá a caneta
para anotar aí tá bom não falar mais
comigo ontem por causa das estações de
metrô outros 6 horas até chegar em casa
antes aqui cheguei em casa por ter vindo
falar comigo fala comigo que não tem
aqui cheguei em casa peguei um papel
anotei beleza dia seguinte acordei
lembrando aqui no figueirense foi lá
liguei e aí no dia 2 de novembro a gente
marcou de se encontrar no parque do
ibirapuera às 9 horas da manhã
bacana 9 horas da manhã cheguei 76 que
não tinha dinheiro para a ii divisão
tinha que de skate ou não e aí pode
antes de chegar lá e dá um tempo
pessoais e capela chegar chorozinho pai
tal beleza ela chegou cinco horas depois
do horário combinado das nove
beleza estava lá mais importante é a
nossa missão vamos lá beleza a gente
ficou lá conversa vai conversa vem não
tinha mais assunto agora é hora do beijo
ela virava pulado
conversa vai conversa vem a gente estava
conversando porque passava um cachorro à
dona do cachorro acaba com o bicho por
velho eu tô aqui com a dona do cachorro
pelo amor de deus devia ter ido por mas
tu pelo menos à noite a cachorrinha
pagava de culto
pois é 15 horas e meia depois de jejum
porque só tinha dois passes de papel que
aquela época da pasta de papel no bolso
a pagar um lanche para nós dois ela como
é lógico não pode botar chegado nem toda
a comida antes de sair de casa
no ponto de ônibus pensando por que será
que eu fiz errado fazer bom uso dela
tava vindo já estava desistindo tem
praticamente a orelha dela para tirar lá
valeu
ela virou meu rosto e eu ganhei o meu
primeiro beijo
hoje outro irmão pois é você deve estar
se perguntando tobón beleza tecnologia
go total que isso tem a ver com
tecnologia anos depois eu descobri que a
tecnologia nada mais é do que você fazer
o melhor que você pode com aquilo que
você tem tanta gente ficar um pouquinho
e voltar no tempo e explicar uma coisa
para vocês
esse moleque aí com toda sua magreza
sou eu e esse carinho nas minhas costas
é o meu irmão
se você reparar na parede lá no fundo é
só reparar que tem alguns papelões na
parede e lá no cantinho na janela está
um pouquinho preto por causa da umidade
que acabou apodrecendo na madeira
esse lugar é o barraco que a gente
morava pouco depois da separação dos
meus pais que a sema emprestou para a
gente morar até que a gente tivesse como
conseguir uma coisa melhor e como
barraca já tinha um tempo de uso
o papelão era a tecnologia mais
acessível e mais barato que a gente
tinha pra conseguir proteger um
pouquinho do frio que como barraca e eu
tinha um pouco de uso estava muito frio
quando fazia java já nada de errado do
evento e quando vem a chuva era pior
ainda
então assim não é nada de grave não é
assim tão complicado mas a gente acabou
tendo algumas perdas
a gente perdeu nosso colchão que a gata
que a gota a gota acabou acontecendo a
água cair atrás do do guarda-roupa
acabou apodrecendo nos uniformes na
gaveta e não deu mais tempo eu tive que
pegar a roupa dos vizinhos e como o
barraco não ficava na mesma linha da rua
quando vinha muita água aquilo é
acumulava e parte do barranco
desmoronava nota que ela fazia marotta
no final do dia se não tirava ali mas
era assim que acontecia na beleza
após um tempo já com 12 anos de idade
6ª série meio do ano praticamente todas
as notas vermelhas possíveis muita falta
e algumas advertências no boletim
eu fui na rua de baixo que tinha asfalto
pra chamar um amigo para jogar taco no
caso battisti taco enfim
e aí tava vindo pra gente jogar ea mãe
dele gritou lá do fundo volta já pra
dentro de casa nem fazer sua lição e
deixa esse sem futuro aí deixa esse sem
futuro
é o tchan
eu confesso a vocês que de uma batidinha
violenta e foi a primeira vez que caiu a
minha ficha
aliás eu descobri anos depois que aquela
foi a minha primeira sessão de coaching
gratuita na faixa beleza
o ponto é que eu fui pra casa pensei
naquilo que falei pô no final ela tem
razão pode fazer rude mas ela tem um
ponta de razão porque continua
exatamente do jeito que eu estou fazendo
as mesmas coisas das duas uma ou repetir
de ano na melhor das hipóteses ou eu vou
sair da escola e talvez de fato meu
futuro esteja comprometida
só que o cara não gostava de estudar
também nem aí ficava só na rua está nem
era uma coisa tão legal entre a galera
da turma eu lembrei do meu pai e com 28
anos só tinha até a 5ª série e com 35 se
formou advogado foi bom se tem alguém
que manja dessa mancharia a estudar esse
caro ninguém pra ele foi pai de outro
passo da amazónia aí tudo tamo junto
e foi aí que eu também a primeira grande
decisão na minha vida e me mudei para
são paulo
o time de são paulo muita coisa
aconteceu eu tive que me adaptar aquela
rotina mas foi a linha naquele dia
naquele ano eu tive contato com meu
primeiro computador primeiro computador
pois é foi praticamente amor à primeira
vista falava cara primeiro tem que botar
tinta no negócio
segundo você está ali digitando aquele
barulho bonito na máquina de escrever
não fazia aquino e você pode botar um
negócio foi até ouvir música não precisa
gastar 1 março também é isso esse é o
futuro
e aí eu precisava desenvolver o hábito
de estudar
lembrei de quem da minha coach falei
tamo junto até mesmo o colegial terminar
o colegial técnico em processamento de
dados ciência da computação e naquele
momento a minha paixão por tecnologia me
fez sonhar em um dia trabalhar em uma
grande empresa a maior do mundo talvez e
podem impactar o máximo de pessoas que
eu pudesse com meu conhecimento e beleza
mas a gente fala dessa história
tecnologia voltar de novo no tempo e vou
falar de 2001 que em 2001 conhecer a
shirley mas eu também conhecer a dona
ana a mãe da cheia
bom meus amigos não entendia muito bem
porque eu amava aquela mulher é uma
mulher incrível um caminho para minha
sogra velho
mas nem só está pegando sua mini 9 sogra
york
a vida não está entendendo não se
entender um pouco do que era do ano
vamos lá não era aquela pessoa
se você chegasse em casa de noite poder
de cansada ela podia ter o pior dia da
vida que ela tem aquele arroz eo feijão
enfrenta um bicho pra você se sente
melhor
a dona ana quando descobriu que gostava
de alface lisa a partida de todos os
domingos depois daquele ela quando ela 5
horas da manhã para ir à feira pegar
melhor alface para fazer aquela
saladinha pra mim do jeito que eu gosto
de mão azeite sal mas nada
a dona quando viu que eu tinha aquela
marca de desodorantes embaixo do braço
do menino que é isso aí dá todas as suas
roupas que agora quem lava roupas foi o
que você não vai arrumar dinheiro seu
trabalho enfim sair é tipo a dona e que
há três coisas que nunca faltava na casa
da dona café muita risada e um projeto
aos cachorro
a dúvida dos cachorros atende pois é o
tempo passou e me casei com a dona do
cachorro foi muito legal
e quando a gente casou impressionante
que algumas coisas aconteceram primeira
corrida do ano já não estava mais no
fogão a gente estava ali a panela ficar
vazia não tinha mais aquele gostosinho
segunda coisa todo mundo começa uma
carta pra gente costuma chamar de boleto
mas é incrível como todo mundo
nossa lembrava da gente bonita pra cá
aquela boletta a danada beleza
nada disso me incomodava tanto quanto a
tal da internet
cara eu contratava uma internet assim e
aí eu tenho impressão que tinha internet
assim em todo chegar em casa colocar uma
vez que parece linha discada a conectar
o celular é possível e eu tentava que
não dava certo e toda vez que chegava em
casa e tinha essa internet ruim
eu ligava na operadora abril chamado
demorava todo mundo faz aquele ping pong
eu tinha certeza todo mundo riu da minha
cara ele demorou pra caramba chamado na
semana seguinte a mesma coisa foi em não
deve ter um jeito de usar a tecnologia
para fazer isso
e foi aí que me lembrei de um curso que
eu tinha feito eo e eu descobri um
computadorzinho a chamada rachel berry
computador de 35 dólares tamanho de um
cartãozinho assim você pode deixar
ligado o dia inteiro ele faz coisas pra
você foi já sei já que a fab chamado
pela internet eu vou colocar o robozinho
o progama ele ele vai ver o nível de
internet que tem ali estiver abaixo da
velocidade contratada e lhe abre um
chamado direto na operadora não preciso
nem vou ver
e foi assim que eu fiz um robô que
começaram a monitorar a internet e
quando estava baixo e não só abriu um
chamado na operadora como ele também se
não tivesse resolvido haviam chamado na
anatel
carteirada falar ele vai resolver o
irmão então para ele a anatel no rolê
pois é depois disso a gente foi lá
estudou pra caramba trabalhou em
diversas empresas é para lá que a gente
planta foi morar fora depois voltou em
2011 quando a gente voltou
eu recebi uma ligação e e nessa ligação
makoun dos momentos mais difíceis da
nossa vida
a dona ana nos deixou com 50 anos de
idade
a dona do feijãozinho mais gostoso já
não estava mais ali entre nós no sábado
não é não é ainda não essa hora
só que foi assim esse é o meu chão de um
filho emprestado não tinha não estava
mais ali imagina o que aconteceu com o
chile
pois é eu olhava para o lado falava cara
cadê as garrafas para resolver esse
problema como é que se resolve o
problema deles não dava para resolver
mas eu lembrei na casa da dona ana só
não falta café risada e os projeto
eu lembrei da minha dona do cachorro eu
falei tá bom uma forma da gente trazer à
tona pra cá de volta ou pelo menos a
memória dela é a gente trazer um projeto
e foi assim que a dupla entrou nas
nossas vidas
só que o pessoal avisou a gente que
buldogue francês tem uma energia
infinita
a gente brincava cada corre pra lá e pra
cá nem o cachorro joga negócio pega
negócio na área da legenda acaba quando
o dente da dupla começou a nascer
as madeiras de casa começou a sumir
rodapé cadeira mesa tudo é o saco foi
cara não é possível tem que ter gente
resolver por mais que eu ficasse
observando a dura mais ligeiro ea
economia vai ter um computador pois é
aquele computador que tinha usado para
monitorar a internet e com computação
visual e uma pia em todas as áreas fixas
da minha casa
a compra uma câmera aquele computador
hack mesa sofá e aí o único polígono que
se mexia dentro dessa casa era a duda
quando o polígono duda
tinha uma intersecção com aquele
polígono que ela não podia eu estava um
time e depois de 30 segundos
aquele computador que estava integrado à
home theater da casa só faltava um
sonzinho não
e foi assim que eu me virei o jogo
contra a dura mais do que isso a minha
vingança foi pior
depois disso veio amendoim e olha a cara
de satisfação da dona
é bronca de seu deus agora pois é bom
pessoal lá atrás eu tinha um sonho de
trabalhar em uma grande empresa muita
coisa aconteceu depois disso eu recebi
um convite que a realização desse sonho
trabalhar em uma das maiores empresas de
tecnologia do mundo
foi incrível quando recebi o convite foi
putz
é isso entrei na empresa foi por muito
legal vão impactar as pessoas com a
tecnologia vai ser incrível primeiro ano
bacana poder diária foi promovido neto
do 2º ano foi agora vai ainda não tem um
terceiro ano bacana também estranho mas
vamos lá que vai dar certo
no quarto ano eu estava me sentindo meio
mal e do 4o 5o
eu me sentia todo dia uma fraude que
adiantou estudar tudo isso de tecnologia
se eu só uso isso pra ir e voltar do
trabalho e não ajuda ninguém com isso
que adianta eu ter feito todos esses
cursos e no final das contas eu só me
beneficiar ou beneficiar meus amigos
minha família e aí algumas pessoas enfim
de propósito mas eu sentia que precisava
fazer alguma coisa ea única certeza que
eu tinha era que eu não podia conseguir
continuar ali eu não sabia o que era
depois mas ali não dava
bom eu lembrei da minha corte e ameaças
a sério e eu lembrei que lá atrás
o melhor que eu pude fazer foi inverter
completamente o jogo e foi em fevereiro
de 2016
eu resolvi tomar a segunda grande
decisão na minha vida que abandonei o
sonho de trabalhar nessa grande empresa
de tecnologia e abracei a tal
assustadora liberdade
só que estava no meio da crise e no meio
da crise irmãos e pedir demissão se não
tem fgts não tem não sei que pouca grana
muita incerteza que você faz economizar
uma grana errado
foi nesse dia que eu percebi que tinha
que expandir
eu tinha que investiu em conhecer o
máximo de pessoas possível e
que dar esse passo e depois a gente vai
ver o que dá depois o universo é dizer
aqui eu vim fazer aqui pois é
fiz um curso de futurismo nessas minhas
investidas e lá esse curso eu conheci
uma galera que tinha um projeto que
falava mais ou menos assim a gente desde
com o tema de enchentes como um grande
tema que impactava muita gente no brasil
o que a gente faz é de chuva em tempo
real
medir temperatura umidade de 10 minutos
é isso que faz uma estação zinha pequena
e tem um custo aproximado de 150 anos
a idéia é justamente essa a gente tem
informação em tempo real
a partir do momento que a chuva começa a
conseguir identificar o comportamento eo
padrão daquela chuva e dependendo
principalmente da intensidade
a gente conseguiu avisar a população com
um certo tempo de antecedência para uma
tomada de decisão de hoje não existe uma
tomada de decisão que hoje não existe
chuva tecnologia ajudar pessoas beleza
precisava dar um presente para um amigo
nosso que tinha em comum e se esse
dispositivo é feito de acrílico existe
uma máquina de cortar aqui foi o pedrão
onde o amor ao ajudar a cortar naquilo
que foi lá enquanto ele estava cortando
o jogo eu estava lá e preocupado com os
código foi aí que tá pegando deus ou o
velho tem como você fazer um orçamento
aí pra gente pra ajudar a gente aqui
nesse projeto que só tem eu ia a gente
não haja tanta assim de programação
talvez a gente precisa de alguém para
dar uma força faz um orçamento o
orçamento é o orçamento
mal sabia ele que não precisava de
orçamento nenhum era exatamente aquilo
eu podia pagar para trabalhar no projeto
de se usar a tecnologia para ajudar as
pessoas cara era isso e aí
apesar de começar a ajudar eles 100% na
bandeirada vambora vamos ajudar depois a
gente vê
eu fui convidado a fazer parte do time
do lyon e foi com muito orgulho que eu
finalmente aceitei e também a terceira
grande decisão na minha vida que me
juntar uma galera que quer usar a
tecnologia que abrir mão daquela zona de
conforto da empresa daquele conforto pra
poder ajudar as pessoas
abraçando aquela assustadora liberdade o
fato é que eu sou grato galera por muita
coisa que aconteceu na minha vida até
hoje muito grato
e quando me chamaram aqui não tem deck
para falar alguma mensagem que eu
pudesse ajudar as pessoas impactar a
primeira coisa que vem à minha mente foi
a minha paixão por tecnologia
mas logo na seqüência veio a minha maior
paixão a paixão que me acompanha há 16
anos a paixão que eu conheci no
ibirapuera
no show de rock depois o meu primeiro
beijo em branco é e ela me torna todo
dia um homem melhor
um homem mais calmo ela me mostra a
beleza da vida sobre os olhos talvez a
zona
pois é durante todo esse tempo a gente
teve uma certeza que tudo muda o tempo
inteiro
assim como na tecnologia em março desse
ano a vida mandou avisar que em dezembro
a nossa vida vai mudar muito vai mudar
para muito melhor pra muito melhor
só que a gente só tem um problema a dona
não tá aqui adoro ela não vai conhecer o
gatinho dela
a gente não tem como perguntar pra ela
como é que faz para ser uma mãe tão
incrível como é que faz para pessoas que
nem são seus filhos se sentirem como se
fosse um como o manual de ser pai de mãe
pois é não tem como a gente perguntar
pra dona o máximo que a gente pode fazer
meu amor é usar tudo que a gente
aprendeu com ela usa tudo todas as
tecnologias que a vida nos deu e talvez
a maior tecnologia de todas
o amor é senão o melhor pai a melhor mãe
mas ser o melhor pai é a melhor mãe que
a gente puder com tudo aquilo que a vida
nos deu até hoje eu tenho uma certeza
durante todo esse tempo a galera aqui em
tecnologia me ensinou que o sistema bom
não é o sistema que nunca falha a gente
faz planos
esse plano vai falhar uma hora ele pode
falhar mas um bom sistema não é aquele
que não falhar é aquele que está
preparado para quando vi a mudança ele
aprender o máximo que ele puder desse
impacto dessa falta de expectativa que
não foi atendida e fazer o melhor que
puder com aquilo e que tal então se a
gente não se cobrasse tanto a gente
usasse todas as tecnologias que a vida
nos
oferece para fazer da forma mais
divertida ilegal possível o melhor que a
gente puder com aquilo que a vida nos
deram muito obrigado
ninguém